my name is Caitlin schrepper I've been
challenged to do freestyle soccer skills
in 25 levels of increasing complexity
[Music]
freestyle soccer is unique in that it
really is the art of movement with the
ball to me complexity is increasingly
difficult techniques and fluidity of
movement there truly are an unlimited
amount of Tricks but this is my personal
interpretation of the challenge level
one knee juggles we're starting with
knee juggles because they are the
simplest thing for an absolute beginner
to learn the most common mistake is
people actually make contact with their
literal knee but it's actually on the
thigh where you want to hit the ball you
will drop it from your hands bring your
leg up to contact the ball with about
the middle of your thigh you want to
start with one juggle at a time right
back to your hands and then do two and
then alternating right left before you
start doing multiple knee juggles most
people tend to bend over just a little
bit but make sure you're not bringing
your chest down to the ball but you're
bringing your knees up level two feet
juggles feet juggles require a couple of
more techniques Than Just Knee juggles
it's about the positioning of your foot
it's locking your ankle it's striking
the ball right on the knuckle of your
big toe and you'll know if you make
proper contact because the ball
shouldn't have too much backspin on it
you want 50 or less of your power when
you're juggling it's not striking the
ball like you would in soccer but it's
also not a hacky sack lift it's a light
swing as if you were sitting in your
chair just like this level three put
stalls the techniques in order to learn
a foot stall and balance a foot stall
really come in helpful for later levels
when you get into things like head
stalls and things like that the best way
to start is to start with the ball in
your hands and literally place it onto
your foot sometimes you want to pull
your toe back to help cushion the ball
and control it right there between your
toes and your shin you'll know you have
the foot stall down when you can just
kind of stand there more relaxed and you
don't really ever feel out of control
now that we've got foot stalls knees and
feet juggles let's move on to level four
flick UPS flick ups are the techniques
that you use to get the ball from the
ground into the air to start freestyle
for the most basic flick up you roll the
ball back and you just chip your toe
right underneath the ball to pop it in
the air a little bit when you want to
get a little bit more interesting you go
from the inside from the outside you can
even flick it up with your heel but that
becomes a little bit more complicated
there's a whole spectrum of flick UPS
one of my favorite flick UPS is called a
slap you start with the ball in between
your ankles you roll your right foot
behind your left and with your right
foot you roll the ball up your left leg
to flick the ball at the band start
juggling level five blocks
sidebot freestyle can be broken down
into four different categories lowers
any sort of revolutions and tricks you
do standing up uppers which are tricks
that you do chest and above sit Downs
which are any tricks you do when you're
sitting or laying down on the ground
blocks are any sorts of catches with the
ball whether it's your knees ankles
that's a block the knee catch drop the
ball with some backspin let it balance
and then catch the ball nice and gently
between your knees so with the angle
catch you want the ball in between your
ankles right on the bone whereas a foot
stall the ball is staying right on top
of your foot the key with blocks is
everything is gentle you don't want to
squeeze the ball too hard so even with
these five levels you can already start
to build your own freestyle combo as
simple as a flick up into a couple of
juggles level six crossovers there are
introduction to lowers they're what we
call a half Revolution trick you can do
it off of a Juggle or even off foot
stalls after you flick that ball up you
want to swing your left foot over the
ball and then you hop up to make contact
with the ball you want to make sure your
body weight is centered still and your
stand mostly upright if not a little
bent over you want to hit about the same
place that you do when you're juggling
so when you juggle your foot is about
parallel to the ground when you do
crossovers you want to pull your toe
back just a little bit to keep the ball
closer level seven help the world we're
moving from a 0.5 Revolution trick into
the Hop the world which is one full
Revolution hop the world is a little
more complicated because you actually
incorporate both feet you start with
their left foot and you end with your
right foot with crossover the left foot
is there but it doesn't actually touch
the ball at any point from here we can
start to build a more interesting combo
you have a couple of lowers tricks now
and we could build with what we call the
basics of freestyle
level 8 around the world around the
world is the most famous Trick In
freestyle soccer you might have seen
Ronaldinho do it you've seen it from the
jogo Bonita ads it is a one revolution
lower strict where you start with say
your right foot one revolution around
the ball and then you end with a touch
with your right foot when you're
normally juggling with the ball you hit
just like this but when you're doing it
around the world you're slicing which
gives it a little bit of Spin A lot of
the times people will kick the ball and
then try to get their foot around that
presents a couple of issues one the ball
tends to go too high and then two in
splitting that into two different
motions the kick and then the revolution
you lose time and it's a lot harder to
get your foot around in time when you do
it in one fluid motion you get the ball
with the right height and you have the
time to get your foot all the way over
level nine to zani around the world
tuzani is actually the name of the
creator of this trick one of the more
notable figures in freestyle the tuzani
around the world is a 1.5 Revolution
trick which is one full Revolution
Edition and then a half a Revolution to
finish so you strike with the knuckle of
your small toe right here one full
revolution around like an around the
world and then to finish it's a
crossover motion at the end the
difficulty with this is striking the
ball with the outside of your foot is a
smaller surface and a lot less room for
error than it is with the inside of your
foot level 10 lemons around the world
lemons around the world is the most
recognizable two Revolution trick
imagine your right foot is starting in
the air and that's the one that's going
to be interacting with the ball you're
jumping off your left foot and doing the
revolutions with your right it's the
same striking technique as the around
the world but the difference with this
one as you make contact with that ball
you want to hop up off your other foot
to give you a little more height you're
making contact here but at the same time
you're jumping and you make that first
Revolution complete the second
revolution as you come down and then you
finish the trick level 11 Advanced
blocks Advanced blocks you can take the
basic blocks and then you start to spice
it up a little bit so rather than
kneecatch straight down to an ankle
catch you go from a kneecatch into a
crossed ankle catch or you could do
things like a thigh grab and then Pop
the ball back up to start juggling
Advanced blocks could come in in a
routine say after a basic block like a
knee catch you go knee to like X ankle
catch a slap flick up it is the spice of
the routine rather than just the
building blocks level 12 clipper
Clipper is one of the more famous tricks
in freestyle it is a stall the same way
that you do a foot stall but with
Clipper it's on the inside of your foot
while your right leg is wrapped behind
your left leg the biggest difficulty
when it comes to Clipper is your foot
positioning because you have to flex
your ankle so that it sits parallel to
the ground with the inside of your foot
face up which is actually not a natural
position for anybody's foot to do so a
lot of people have to stretch their foot
in order to get it to reach that
position now that we've started to
incorporate a little bit of spice into
our routine we can get a little more
interesting now we're going to move to
the floor and we're going to do level 13
sit Downs sit down crossovers are one of
the simplest tricks that you can learn
sitting down you'll want to be sitting
upright hands on the floor behind you
cross your left leg over the top and
make contact with your right foot when
it comes to sit-downs the biggest
difference is in the foot positioning
lock your ankle still but rather than
parallel to the floor it's a little bit
more pointed and you want to make Con
contact with the same part of your foot
but the key with this is your foot can't
be super far from you you need to keep
your knees bent and your feet close to
your chest whenever I think of sit-down
crossovers I always remember the show
when I had to learn them I was front and
center on the stage on Broadway and I
was probably about six seven months into
freestyle I had to do sit-down
crossovers never Having learned them
before and so now every time I do them I
just get a nice little flashback level
14 Soul stall so with soul stall you're
going to be laying on your back your
legs going to be up in the air almost
locked out and the ball is going to be
balancing on the sole of your foot while
it's right above you the easiest way to
train this is to just place the ball on
top of your Sole and learn to balance it
it's an awkward thing for most people
and you really have to learn the
technique of just balancing the ball at
first you're ready to learn a soul stall
when you have basic sit-downs down you
need the patience that it takes to learn
all the previous tricks in order to
learn Soul it took me eight months level
15 raise Soul stall swipes same
technique as a soul stall except now
you're rolling back so you're just
balancing on your shoulders your hands
are supporting your waist and your leg
is going to be a little bit higher up in
the air you have that ball balanced in a
stall You're Gonna Pop the ball up and
you're gonna swipe your left leg
underneath the ball and then catch it
again so it's here Pop the ball up swipe
under and catch
level 16 by pop by pop is often used as
one of the most beginner transitions but
it can be used just as a trick in and of
itself so with the thigh pop you'll
start sitting down you'll catch the ball
right behind your leg in a thigh grab
you want to roll onto your side point
the ball up towards the sky and you'll
straighten your leg to Pop the ball up
level 17 no touch combo no touch combos
are combinations of two or more tricks
take a crossover in tuzani but the
difference here is that you're not doing
the two tricks individually you're
taking out all of the excess touches to
make it one fluid combination to do a no
touch combo you take out the extra trick
in the middle cross over and you would
go straight into a tuzani level 18
headstall now we're moving on to uppers
and head stall is the most basic uppers
building walk to learn the ball is on
your hairline you want to make sure
you're looking up at the ball the whole
time and you want to stand a little bit
upright with your head tilted back and
your knees Bend just a little bit
headstyles coming in at level 18 because
in a combo you would be kicking the ball
up and then balancing the ball from
there but you're working with your head
here so you can't really flex your head
or things like that and it's really
about using your entire body to cushion
the ball and you shift your whole body
weight to bounce the ball level 19
around the moon when around the Moon
your head is moving around the ball
rather than the ball moving around your
head this time you would start from a
next doll you would flick it up to the
side and your head and your chest rotate
around the ball to catch again on the
back of your neck the way I explain to
everyone is you kind of have chicken
wings the ball is sitting on the back of
your neck from there rotate off to the
side and flip lick the ball up at the
same time almost like tossing it up to
the side you're really just isolating
your upper body your feet should stay
planted and it's just your chest and
head that are moving level 20 lip stall
lip stall is a little bit harder than
around the Moon because you're working
with a very small surface to balance the
ball with and it's not flat your lips
are in an odd place where there's not a
lot of body behind it when you're doing
it you're tilted back and your lips are
right here you really have to get the
perfect positioning to stall that ball
for more than say a second at a time to
do a combo incorporating a lip stall
typically I would do something like next
doll around the Moon into a head stall
and then the simplest way to transition
into a lip stall would be tilt your head
back and let the ball roll down right
onto your lips level 21 lemon Smith
around the world the lemon's Mitch name
comes from the creators of two
individual tricks with the techniques
combined so a lemon snitch around the
world is a 2.5 Revolution trick you jump
off your left foot you make the two
revolutions that last Revolution has to
be a little bit quicker because at the
same time that left leg will come over
the ball cross over the top and then you
Pop the ball up this one is a little bit
more complex because it requires a lot
more speed it requires a little bit more
power in your jump than say a lemons
around the world if you're trying to
become a complete well-rounded
freestyler learning all the different
four categories you would want to learn
the basics of every category before you
start incorporating the higher
difficulty tricks things like anything
above a two Revolution trick that
require weeks and months of practice
level 22 transitions
transition is any trick that will take
you from one category to another whether
it's lowers to sit Downs sit-downs to
lowers so we briefly mentioned
transition tricks before but we're
putting it as level 22 because now
you're starting to incorporate it
fluidly in the middle of a combo not
just at the end for this one it would be
a step over slap into sitting down you
would go from a kneecatch drop it like
you're doing a crossed ankle catch but
right away you're going to roll the ball
up the back of your left leg duck under
the ball and then transition to sitting
down there's really no set in stone
number of transition tricks they are how
everyone expresses their own personal
style it is kind of the Pinnacle of
personal Flair when it comes to
Freestyle these Advanced combos become a
lot more complex because you're taking
out all the unnecessary touches and
you're replacing them with little bits
of personal flares
level 23 acrobatic tricks these tricks
are anything from like flips to
handstands I used to be a gymnast so I
incorporate a lot of gymnastic movements
into my tricks flip tricks are anything
like a kip up when you're laying on your
back the ball is stalled in a soul stall
roll back a little bit push off of your
hands kick up into a standing position
level 24 is my signature trick cat flip
it comes from rhythmic gymnastics you
start with the ball in a next doll and
you will kick up into a handstand the
ball is still stalled on the back of
your neck flip your feet over your head
into a back bend the ball is still
caught between the back of your neck and
the lower part of your back from there
you'll stand up and drop it into a thigh
catch
level 25 the final combo the point of
the final combo is to fully express
yourself it's really about taking all of
the small techniques that you can and
incorporating as many as you possibly
can you want to do the big tricks the
lemons Mitch around the world the
transitions but what really creates the
full combo is the small style points
that you add in between you don't want
to see a seam it's like when you create
clothing you don't want to see the seam
of the clothing it's one fluid almost
dance routine
[Music]
the beauty of freestyle is that there's
no limits to it we're constantly
inventing New Tricks more revolutions
more acrobatics more unique tricks this
challenge was so interesting to do
because it kind of felt like a very
condensed journey through all of my 10
years of freestyle but also it's making
me re-examine freestyle through the lens
of someone just starting it all over
again now that I have all of these
techniques now that I've Incorporated in
my own personal style it's making me see
how I can share that with you and see
what kind of freestyle is we can create
take your time be patient and you'll get
there
foreign
[Music]